je fais partie de ceux qui dès le départ
ont considéré que la solution à la
situation à laquelle nous étions
confrontés en 2013 la solution n'était
pas militaire
parce que dans le cadre de mes de nos
combats au niveau du mouvement social
mondial je sais ce qui s'est passé en
irak en afghanistan pourquoi on entre en
guerre on n'entre pas en guerre et parce
qu'on veut sauver d'un pays on entre en
guerre parce que et les intérêts
dominants l'exigent alors je suis parti
du fait que l alibi ce qui s'est passé
en libye et mettez en péril et la
sécurité la paix la sécurité et
d'honorer dans nos régions plus
particulièrement au mali
à la faveur de l'ol l'opération serval
serval et a été transformé en barres
quand on n'a pas demandé l'avis est du
mali niger quoi pas de quatre autres
pays du g5 sahel les gens sont sortis
vous souvenez l'immense majorité des
maliens qui n'en pouvait plus et de la
situation créée dans le nord et par les
djihadistes et donc et la rébellion à
l'époque
donc les gens ont cru effectivement que
et la france est libre harpiste que
comme et promis ce n'était pas une
guerre qui devait durer
donc comme vous le dites et sept ans
plus tard et barkan s'enlise
nous nous quand nos morts par milliers
mais non j'ai entendu dire que barkan
est appelée à rester au moins 30 ans et
présentant le redoute ici et on dit que
ce serait notre vietnam à nous le mari
et vous des gens ne leur donne pas tort
et je ne la donne pas tort
[Musique]